[Music]
finally i'm turning the skater boy song
into a film people lost their collective
minds when they found out that this
thing was happening this is something
that i've been working on for a while
and i'm really excited i took my high
school experience threw it into
a song
and now we're just gonna dive deeper and
it's going to be an extension of this
song and the message in it
[Music]
do you have like a dream casting list
for it because i mean off the top of my
head i'm like mgk megan fox to me makes
a little bit of sense i don't know if
their ages match up to what you're
looking for like i am definitely hitting
up my friends my musician friends to
make cameos in this because it'll be
really fun i was talking to mark hoppus
the other day i was like mark you have
to make it cameo in my skater boy movie
and he was like i'm in he could be like
a cool teacher or like something in it
it's hard to believe that avril's debut
album let go featuring huge hits like
skater boy turns 20 this year what's
your relationship like now as a woman to
those songs they came from me i've
written on all of my songs
and all seven albums i still love
performing like all my hits from over
the years because it's like
when you achieve that my music taking
off and at the level it did that's just
so unique and special and that's
something i'm really proud of
[Music]